if you stop and you think about
everything we hold a value on this
planet metals minerals energy real
estate the things that nations fight
wars over these things are in near
infinite quantities out there if you
believe that the developing world
deserves the same standards of living
that we do in the developed world then
to achieve that they need resources they
need the metals and the minerals to
build the industries and the buildings
and so forth and the energy and the
question is do you continue to rape and
pillage earth or if you had the ability
to extract that information from the
outside resources outside of Earth then
that would be a mechanism to uplift the
bottom billion or so of society the
other thing is that there's on Sept that
a friend of mine Elon Musk and I talked
about backing up the biosphere you know
go back to ancient history and when the
libraries of Alexandria burned and all
the knowledge was consumed in those
flames today we have built this pinnacle
of information both in the biosphere
encoded in the genomics of plants and
animals and the billions of species on
this planet and in the internet where
we've digitized languages information
and images and so forth you know the
right size asteroid coming in to smack
the earth will destroy all of that so we
have today literally the technical
capability to back up the living Earth
if you would back up Gaia digitally and
to go and sequence the genomes of not
billions but millions of species and
take that information and duplicate it
off the planet such that if anything
ever happened its resident there and
preserved forever that sort of
capability comes with it a tremendous
moral imperative in my mind of being
able to implement this so those are some
of the reasons to uplift society and to
back up the biosphere and the third and
final reason is it's in our genome we
we are as humans exploring species you
know we began the plains of Africa and
our need to explore that took us into
Europe into Asia across the Straits into
the Americas and so forth that drive to
explore is resident in our DNA in fact
it's genetically if you would selected
for because those who explore and move
out the widest and furthest have the
least chance of having their genome you
know destroyed by a local accident and
so that is a evolutionary imperative
we're not going to stop here on planet
earth we're going to move out to other
planetary bodies and not I believe not
going into the planetary you know
gravitational wells will build societies
and in you know O'Neill like spheres and
and humanity will move out into the
cosmos and probably meet other societies
that have done the same and millennia
neons past
something very interesting has happened
over the last hundred years that people
don't think about which is that the
frontiers that we have have started to
shrink and disappear it used to be that
100 or 150 years ago if you screwed up
you know you up literally in one
area you're you could go and start again
someplace you you could go and and start
your life again without the stigma of
what happened there's no place you can
do that again there's no real frontiers
so that ability the second thing about
frontiers are it allows the individuals
who are best whether they're men or
women or minorities or whatever to to
step up to the top so in traditional
societies you know old world societies
in the you know the United Kingdom if
you would if you were born into the
right Stratus the right class you had
the ability to succeed but if you
weren't you were stuck and in the
frontier and it didn't matter what your
birthright was where you went to school
what you did if you are the best people
came to you so that's some of the
elements of a frontier and finally in
space what's going to happen is the
chance to truly explore in different
societal structures if you want to
practice a pure capitalist state or
Anarchy or socialism whatever it is you
can gather the people around you who
want to you know to form that type of
government and go and create your own
space society off on some colony and go
and practice that knows who don't like
it can duplicate the genomics and the
knowledge systems of that colony and
split out and do it again there will be
the Darwinian evolution of different
forms of society in different ways of
people trying it but you know go and try
and start your own government here in
the United States today and you'll be
squashed very quickly
one of the precepts of the x prize is
you get what you incentivize very simple
concept that's extremely powerful and if
you look to the root of what the
problems are you always find out well we
don't incentivize that today to what we
incentivize we incentivize you know a
congressman be elected every two years a
president being like it over four years
and center over six years so it's what's
going to affect people right now what
can I promise and deliver in two years
space is not a two-year objective it
used to be in the early 60s we had this
eye candy of mercury and Gemini and
Apollo every year we would do something
more and more in it it met those needs
but the easy stuffs been done you know
and today NASA call stuff nominal
instead of phenomenal like it really is
so you know I've given up that that you
know there's going to be a balance and
NASA's going to do certain things and we
are finally in a state of existence
we're small groups of individuals can do
extraordinary things funded by single
people you know today a group of 20
individuals empowered by the exponential
growing technologies of AI and robotics
and computers and networks and
eventually nanotechnology can do what
only nation states could have done
before we saw this in the first XPrize
that we put together the Ansari XPrize
we're a spaceship one built by a small
team of 20 individuals that scaled
composites led by burt rutan funded by
one individual paul allen did what you
know only the United States government
could have done 40 years earlier we see
that more and more coming up